c'est alain chamfort alors si vous
voulez écouter mes chansons vous cliquez
là si vous voulez vous abonner à ina
chanson vous cliquez là
ça vient la fin d'une tournée acoustique
que je veux avec thiré liesse depuis
maintenant quelques années et c'est le
démarrage d'une autre tournée avec un
groupe
voilà on sera à cinq sur scène du quatre
musiciens excellents et plus ce mois et
donc on part après on tournait jusque
avril 2017
c'est un programme qui à la fois intègre
une partie des chansons du dernier album
parce que c'est bien d'être toujours un
peu dans l'actualité quand même et en
même temps c'est un tour d'horizon aussi
effectivement ce rôle voilà tout ce que
j'ai écris depuis pas mal d'années
maintenant
excepté je crois à la période flèche là
que j'ai pas retenu parce que sinon on
n'en sort plus coincé pendant sa sert a
duré trop longtemps et je crois que les
changes
je vous faut au delà de certaines un
certain temps que qui et je dirai entre
1h30 et 2h maximum tout le reste un peu
superflu et les gens finissent par
s'ennuyer un peu donc voilà je suis de
construit tout un programme qui fait
qu'ils respectent mais différentes
périodes mais malheureusement pour
certains qui l'attend peut-être lira pas
la période coup de françois et
généralement il ya quand même toujours
eu une fan base comme on dit enfin ces
gens qui sont fidèles depuis de
nombreuses années et qui sont toujours
fidèles à ces rendez vous donc cela je
fini par reconnaître une bonne partie
on était les premiers c'était vraiment à
s'inspirer des émissions de télévision
américaine c'est pas eux qui ont créé
mais c'est la première les premières
émissions à la télévision française sur
laquelle on proposait des duos voir des
trios ou demander des artistes de de
jouer la comédie ensemble de participer
à un peu de s'oublier un petit peu
eux-mêmes et de d'être au service de
l'émission ce qu'un peu a réussi à faire
aller bien des années plus tard les
l'état d'esprit des restos du coeur
jean jacques goldman s'est inspiré un
petit peu de cette émission de
carpentier parce que ça a laissé un
souvenir tout à fait sympathique à tout
le monde dans la période des années 70
les carpentier proposer quelque chose de
de plus chiadé quoi avec eux c'était
assez sophistiqué de travailler pour eux
et d'ailleurs il était assez exigeant
dans leur casting et sélectionner les
gens pas moi au compte gouttes et pour
rentrer dans leur cercle
on sait pas à quoi ça tu sais tu tenais
mais c'était quand même un privilège
donc mais le jour où par contre coup une
veine ont été acceptées par les
carpentier et bien c'était une famille
qui ce qui s'ouvrait une nouvelle
famille qui s'ouvrait à nous où on avait
la possibilité
voilà d'être valorisés c'est à dire une
vraie mise en valeur dans leur émission
un souci de de la mise en scène de
l'éclairage la qualité des deux des
interventions enfin c'était les
émissions que tu es préparer à l'avant
ce que tu es répéter ces voix-là des
émissions que tu ai réfléchi et avec des
gens qui avaient le sens du respect de
leurs publics etc
donc voilà
il avance et une période qui paraît un
peu ancienne maintenant et qu'on peut
regretter mais dont beaucoup s'inspire
ou essaie de s'inspirer encore
aujourd'hui et certains autres devraient
s'en inspirer parce que ça fait partie
des choses dont on peut être fier à la
télévision l'idéal est elle est possible
aujourd'hui effectivement comme tu dis
c'est un peu comme la creative common où
les gens réutilise des choses
préexistantes et les amène ailleurs les
et repartir une nouvelle création à la
musique permet ça depuis un petit moment
quand même parce que bien souvent on a
et ça m'est arrivé moi aussi le faire de
samples et des parties de batterie ou
des choses comme ça qui est que je l ai
récupérées sur des enregistrements
préexistants là disons que c'est tout
l'album qui propose ce travail-là quoi
avec des gens de cette scène électro
française exclusivement et mais je
trouve ces des procédés tout à fait
actuelle et qu'il faut évidemment à mon
avis encourager à la fois c'est un peu
déstabilisant parce que c'est assez loin
de notre propre travail puisque pour
certains d'entre eux ils n'ont retenu
que très peu d'éléments de 2,2 ce que je
leur ai fourni en même temps c'est
intéressant de voir ce que même certains
petits éléments d'une chanson peut les
amener eux et les inspirer pour leur
propre univers voilà en fonction de deux
des artistes qui ont été concernés par
cet album il y en a qui sont vraiment
rapprocher assez précisément de ce que
j'avais prévu
proposez moi et d'autres qui sont sont
véritablement trop éloignés et je trouve
que de toute façon d'une manière ou
d'une autre moi ça me convenait puisque
puisque je leur ai proposé d'utiliser
mon travail comme bon leur semblait donc
fallait on accepter toutes les
possibilités et c'est ce que je fais
avec grand plaisir
manureva quand tu ne me plaît enfin bien
sûr c'est vrai que c'est un peu
différent des autres parce que connu ce
succès et que beaucoup de gens l'ont
apprécié donc ça ça crée une relation un
peu différente
je suis très associé à cette chanson
dans le regard des gens et je suis
obligé même si je fais avec plaisir de
la chanter à chaque concert voilà je
trouve qu'elle correspondait vraiment à
quelque chose d'assez particulier pour
moi parce que on a c'est une chanson qui
est très difficile à retravailler
d'ailleurs il a ôté la voix est là où
qui l'aï laissé beaucoup sur l'intro etc
enfin il ay la fin c'était très malin la
façon dont dont il a remixé manureva
quai qui est relativement intouchable
parce que cette version elle avait tout
pour pour que ça fonctionne
bon c'est un peu quelque chose qu'on
maîtrise pas totalement nous on était
très heureux de retrouver de la façonner
la réaliser 2,2 dessous de ce qu'on
entend des cas la finalité mais on
savait pas si ça allait être partagé par
beaucoup de gens partout enfin voilà et
s'est trouvé que ça a été un gros succès
donc c'est vrai que voilà je peux le
peut être que content de cette chanson
et elle peut aussi servir à attirer des
gens vers moi et et à les intéresser et
par curiosité à découvrir d'autres
choses on qu' on ne peut avoir que des
vertus finalement j'écoute cet album
dans la continuité et je trouve que le
passage d'un titre à l'autre est
extrêmement à chaque fois on redémarre
sur une autre histoire
on repart on a des éléments qui nous de
réminiscences comme ça ou non de la
chanson mon timbre pour un voyage etc
l'ensemble que j'aime bien j'ai aussi du
mal dans le contexte de l'album remix et
de faire un choix plutôt qu'un autre
parce que je trouve que
son écoute global me convient
parfaitement
red hat
pour deux
ouvrir pour re découvrir mes chansons
vous pouvez vous abonner à la chaîne et
la chanson